i have realized that there is a high  degree of confusion in the u.s foreign  policy towards this part of the world  it is understandable because these  changes are unprecedented  but the u.s needs in order to to  continue  to preserve its  role and status in the world needs to  design  a cohesive strategy  that understands the reality but also  that under identifies the interests of  both of the us and of the countries and  peoples of the middle east  the reluctance to develop long-term  policies and strategies and the reliance  on short-term tactics  will always  lead to negative results  people  and individuals of the art of countries  people in egypt people in syria people  in tunisia  you name it in any country and the  middle east will keep  in their track in until they  realize their objectives freedom dignity  and social justice